the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of Thrones
foreshadowing video in today's video I
actually want to talk about a couple
different topics as most of you know
every once in a while I like to make
foreshadowing videos what I like to do
is try to figure out how Game of Thrones
will come to an end and sometimes you
can find the answers by taking a look at
some of the older scenes from previous
seasons there are clues throughout the
entire show you just have to know where
to find them so that's what I want to
try to do today I also want to talk
about one of the quotes from the books
because it could be foreshadowing
something as well now I know Game of
Thrones doesn't always follow the books
but we do know the producers did discuss
the ending with the writer george RR
martin according to them they want to
try to end the show in a similar fashion
so you never know what information from
the books is still relevant or not
obviously they haven't been making
everything up because they told us some
of the stuff in this show will
eventually happen in the books too now
let's take a look at the first scene I
want to show you because it may or may
not be foreshadowing a big event in the
final season the scene I want to show
you took place in the first season of
the show when Robert Baratheon is still
the king of Westeros and Ned Stark is
the hand to the king this is when Robert
Baratheon finds out the nares Targaryen
is pregnant and as we all know Robert
wanted her and her baby to die but Ned
Stark could not allow something like
that to happen now the reason why I want
to talk about this scene is because of
something Varys says to Ned if you are
one of my new subscribers then you might
not know this but I actually think Varys
well betrayed Daenerys next season this
is something I have made a video about
before but I never played that scene in
the video because quite honestly I had
forgotten what he said during that scene
otherwise I would have shown it as well
now just in case you did not see the
original video I will briefly tell you
why I think that that way you are not
left completely in the dark
whenever I make a Theory video I try to
provide enough evidence for it to make
sense you can't really do that if you
just show one scene or read one quote
otherwise it could just be seen as a
coincidence especially when it comes to
Barriss betraying Daenerys because some
people think he would never do this
however in my opinion it seems like they
had been foreshadowing this for a very
long time
not to mention Varys isn't a person you
could really trust now if you're
wondering why Varys would do something
like this just take a listen to what he
says because he gave us the answer back
in the first season you might speak
sense to this honorable fool I
understand your misgivings my lord truly
I do it is a terrible thing we must
consider a vile thing yet we who presume
to rule must sometimes do vile things
for the good of the realm should the
gods grant Daenerys a son the realm will
be as you can see Varys said sometimes
you have to do vile things for the good
of the realm now what makes this scene
even more interesting is what he said
right before it ended he said if
Daenerys Targaryen has a son the realm
will bleed as we all know Daenerys never
ended up having that baby but the crazy
thing is Daenerys might be pregnant as
we speak in that scene could come full
circle now when it comes to his loyalty
to Daenerys this is where it gets kind
of tricky because we do know Varys was
secretly trying to get the Targaryen
back on the Iron Throne there was
whispers of this in the first season but
at that time Varys was trying to get
Viserys on the throne not Daenerys if
you remember correctly Varys was trying
to help Robert kill Daenerys if he truly
wanted Daenerys to live then he would
have spoke up when they told Robert not
the killer but he never did Varys
continued to allow this to happen His
grace has had a change of heart
concerning Daenerys Targaryen whatever
Arrangements you made
unmake them at once I'm afraid those
birds have flown God is like he dead
already
now of course this was a very long time
ago
so perhaps Varys no longer feels that
way but as I said before it seems like
the show continues to foreshadow a
betrayal coming from Varys his loyalty
was put into question when Tyrion and
Varys held a meeting what can Farah now
keep this in mind can Vera actually has
a higher position than Melisandre can
Vera might know more about Varys than
she does in my opinion can vara made it
very clear she knows things that only
Varys would know should I tell you what
the voice said should I tell you the
name of the one who spoke
[Music]
we serve the same queen if you're her
true friend you have nothing to fear
from me
conveyor knows what the voice said from
the flames and she also knows that varus
can not be trusted
think about it like this can Vora did
not say anything to Tyrion she did not
question Tyrians loyalty
she only questioned Varys is loyalty
what she said to Varys was a threat
because she knows his intentions in my
opinion this was foreshadowed again when
Daenerys finally had the chance to
confront him
Varys actually admitted trying to have
Daenerys killed
now the nars does forgive him but she
promises if he ever betrays her she will
have him burned alive who sent word to
Essos to murder Daenerys Targaryen grace
I did what had to be done to keep
yourself alive Lord Varys has proven
himself a loyal servant proven himself
loyal quite the opposite if he dislikes
one Manik he conspires to crown the next
one what kind of a servant is that and I
swear this if you ever betray me I'll
burn you alive the tension continues to
build as we get closer to the end then
of course the cherry has put on taught
when Varys speaks with Melisandre every
time Varys speaks to a red priestess he
fears for his life this is not a
coincidence
just like Melisandre said Varys will die
in Westeros next season
I will return their Spyder one last time
m'lady I have to die in this strange
country just like you so now you have to
ask yourself how will varus die he will
not die in battle because he's not a
fighter we've never seen him pick up a
weapon so there's no reason to think he
would all of a sudden decide to want to
help fight the white walkers varus will
end up doing some sneaky [ __ ] once again
but this time it will lead to his death
everybody who's interested himself know
me when I see what desire does to people
what it's done to this country I am very
glad to have no part in you besides the
absence of desire leaves one free to
pursue other things such as all right
now I want to shift gears and talk about
something else the next scene I want to
show you takes place in season 7 during
a conversation between Tyrion Lannister
and Daenerys Targaryen in this video
clip Daenerys tells Tyrion why she
actually likes him but it's not exactly
the answer Tyrion was looking for
Daenerys talks about heroes and how
they're always getting themselves killed
trying to one-up each other she mentions
called Drogo Jorah Mormont and Daario
but who she is really talking about is
Jon Snow because at that time he's on a
mission to capture all white let's take
a look at the scene
I honestly don't you're not a hero oh
I've been heroic on occasion I once
charged through the Medicaid of King's
Landing I didn't want you to be heroes
do stupid things and they die drago
Jorah Daario even this Jon Snow they all
try to outdo each other as of right now
that quote isn't entirely true
Drogo did die but Daario Jorah and Jon
are still alive but could that be
foreshadowing a future event
I don't expect us to ever see Daario
again so let's just leave him out of the
conversation for now could Daenerys
Targaryen be right when it comes to
Jorah Mormont and Jon Snow I would say
both of these men do love Daenerys
Targaryen Jorah Mormont was the first
person to volunteer to go into mission
to capture a white because he is willing
to do just about anything for Daenerys
at this point he lives to serve her and
there may come another time when Jorah
Mormont puts his own life on the line to
keep Daenerys Targaryen safe in fact I
think a lot of people expect Jorah
Mormont to sacrifice himself for
Daenerys next season I know people
believe that because I see them say it
in a comment section all the time but
what about Jon Snow will he end up doing
something stupid to get himself killed
like Daenerys said this is something I'd
like to talk about especially when it
has to do with characters like John
Daenerys Cersei Jaime Tyrion and a few
others
because they are essentially the main
characters of the show obviously
whatever happens to them matters because
it will have a very big impact on the
end of the story now when it comes to
Jon Snow
I believe the chances of him getting
himself killed when doing something
heroic are higher than ever not only
because it's the final season not only
because he has a closer relationship
with Daenerys but also because Daenerys
might be pregnant with this child if
that is the case John seems like the
type of man that would want to protect
his child no matter what even if that
means giving up his own life but even if
you take all those variables off the
table John still has a very good chance
of getting himself killed regardless
John cannot avoid the bloodshed because
he needs to lead the men into battle
john has been preparing for this day for
a very long time and the fact that he is
who he is puts a very big target on his
back
Cersei wants him dead but the night king
also
his eyes on John snow so it doesn't
really matter if John is fighting the
night Kings army or fighting against
Circe's army John has a bull's-eye
painted on his back so let's just say I
will not be surprised if Daenerys is
right about Jorah Mormont or John Snow
all right now let's take a look at one
more thing this time I want to take a
look at one of the quotes from the books
the reason why I want to talk about this
is because it actually goes against a
very popular theory in fact it actually
goes against one of my own theories for
those of you that have seen most of my
videos you and know I think there is a
very good chance that Arya Stark and
ginjury could end up together in the end
the first time I talked about this was
roughly two years ago and I think I have
talked about it in a few other videos
since but the quote I want to show you
today could actually foreshadow someone
else ending up again jury instead and
one of Jaime Lannister's chapters and A
Dance with Dragons he's talking about
both of the stark daughters at this time
in the books
some people believe Arya Stark is
actually in the north but as we all know
she is still in Essos you see in the
books Ramsay Bolton never married Sansa
Stark
he actually marries her friend who goes
by the name of Jane Poole but when rains
he marries her they're trying to
disguise her as Arya Stark that way the
Bolton's have a stronger claim in the
north they dressed Jane up and some
stark clothing and they start to call
her Arya and the rumors of Arya Stark
getting married to Ramsay start to
spread throughout Westeros in this
chapter Jaime mentions Arya getting
married but he also thinks about Sansa
he is hoping Brienne can find her and
keep her safe and he even hopes that one
day she can get married - the
interesting thing is Jaime thinks about
what type of man Sansa can marry take a
look at the quote and let me know if you
think it has any meaning to it Lord
Eddard's daughters live one has just
been Wed the other Brienne where are you
have you found her if the gods are good
she'll forget she was a stark she'll Wed
some burly blacksmith or fat-faced in
keep fill up his house with children and
never need to fear that some night might
come along to smash their heads against
a wall
now this could just be a random thought
Jaime had or maybe it could come true we
know from the beginning of the story
Robert Baratheon always wanted to join
his house when Ned Stark Robert was
never able to do this by getting married
to Leona stark but he later hoped that
Sansa can marry his
Joffre but we all know how that turned
out however there is still another
opportunity for this to happen through
his bastard son ginjury if this were to
happen I think most of us believe REO
would be the one to marry ginjury
because of their close relationship with
one another but some people also think
that REO would never settle down and get
married because this is something that
she told her father now I'm not sure if
Sansa would ever want to get married
again because she's had nothing but bad
experiences with marriage but we all
know Gendry is nothing like Joffrey or
Ramsay Sansa and Gangji have never met
but they are closer to the same age and
they will meet next season when ginjury
arrives and Winterfell to make weapons
so let me know if you think Jayme could
be right could Sansa be the one to end
up with the blacksmith instead Robert
thought he would join houses what Ned by
having Sansa marry his son maybe he was
right the whole time only he had the
wrong son in mind we were meant to rule
together if your sister had lived would
have been bound by blood well it's not
too late I have a son you have a
daughter put your thoughts or questions
down below I would like to see what you
think I know it's just one simple quote
but you never know anyways I want to
thank everyone for taking the time to
watch today's video I appreciate that as
always and I also want to thank those of
you who support the channel on patreon I
hope you all have a great day I'll see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you